>> Laura: GIVEN HER RECENT
MEDIA APPEARANCES, IT’S PRETTY
CLEAR THAT SUSAN RICE IS GOING
TO BE JOE BIDEN’S NUMBER TWO.
YESTERDAY SHE REVEALED HER
POLITICAL AMBITIONS.
SHE DID SO WHEN SHE COMMENTED ON
WHAT HAS LARGELY TURNED OUT TO
BE A VERY MURKY STORY CONCERNING
RUSSIAN BOUNTIES ON AMERICAN
SOLDIERS IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> THIS IS NOT THE TIME TO BE
HANDING PUTIN AND OLIVE BRANCH.
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO IS DOING
OUR ARCH ADVERSARIES BIDDING IT
WOULD SEEM, AND HE IS SURROUNDED
BY SYCOPHANTS AND WEAKLINGS WHO
AREN’T DOING THEIR JOBS, WHO
DON’T HAVE THE CONFIDENCE IN
THEMSELVES AND IN THE MISSION
THAT THEY ARE THERE TO CARRY
OUT.
TO BRING THE PRESIDENT THE TOUGH
MESSAGES HE NEEDS TO HEAR.
>> Laura: ONE OF THE TARGETS
OF THAT SMEAR, SECRETARY OF
STATE MIKE POMPEO, HE JOINS ME
EXCLUSIVELY NOW.
MR. SECRETARY, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
I KNOW YOU FEEL THAT REISS’
REMARKS SHOW A LACK OF RESTRAINT
THAT OUR COUNTRY CAN’T AFFORD TO
HAVE BACK IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
EXPLAIN IT.
>> LAURA, THINKS FOR HAVING ME
ON.
TO HEAR AMBASSADOR RICE TALK
THAT WAY IS JUST CRAZY.
SHE HAS A HISTORY OF GOING ON
SUNDAY SHOWS ONLINE.
YOU’LL REMEMBER IN 2012 SHE WENT
ON FIVE SUNDAY SHOWS AND WHEN
THE PEOPLE HAD PERISHED IN
BENGHAZI, LIBYA, SHE MADE UP A
STORY ABOUT A VIDEO WHEN SHE
KNEW FULL WELL THIS WAS A TERROR
ATTACK.
SHE DID SO BECAUSE IT WAS
POLITICALLY CONVENIENT TO SAY
THAT AND IT’S THE WORST KIND OF
BEHAVIOR FROM A NATIONAL
SECURITY LEADER AND AS FOR
COMMENTS ABOUT RUSSIA, IT WAS
UNDER THE SUSAN RICE’S WATCH,
UNDER VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN’S
WATCH THAT UKRAINE HAD ONE FIFTH
OF ITS REAL ESTATE TAKEN BY
VLADIMIR PUTIN WITH VIRTUALLY NO
RESPONSE.
HE WAS UNDER HER WATCH THAT
SYRIA WAS HANDED OVER TO THE
RUSSIANS AS A RESULT OF A
REDLINE THAT OBAMA HAD DRAWN IN
THE SAND WITHIN REFUSED TO
ENFORCE AND YOU’LL RECALL WHEN
IT COMES TO HAVING AMERICAN
SOLDIERS TAKEN CARE OF, ONE SHE
SUGGESTS THIS ADMINISTRATION
DIDN’T DO, BUT AS ALWAYS IT WAS
HER ADMINISTRATION THAT WAS
UNDERWRITING THE IRANIAN REGIME
WHILE IT WAS KILLING AMERICAN
SOLDIERS IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
THAT WAS THE ADMINISTRATION THE
DIDN’T CARE ABOUT OUR SOLDIERS,
SAILORS, AIRMEN, AND MARINES AND
DIDN’T ACT IN A WAY THAT WAS
SECURING AMERICA’S NATIONAL
INTEREST.
>> Laura: MR. SECRETARY, WE
DON’T HAVE TO PLAY THE
SOUND BITE BUT JOHN BOLTON
ESSENTIALLY IN HIS NEVER ENDING
MEDIA TOUR FOR HIS BOOK, HE SAID
IT’S INCONCEIVABLE THAT THE
PRESIDENT WOULDN’T HAVE BEEN
BRIEFED ON THIS REPORT ABOUT
RUSSIA.
YOUR RESPONSE TO HIS CONTINUED
PUSH AGAINST THE ADMINISTRATION
ON THESE MATTERS OF NATIONAL
SECURITY.
>> YEAH, I DON’T WANT TO GO BACK
AND FORTH WITH JOHN BOLTON OTHER
TO SAY THAT MUCH OF WHAT HE HAD
IN HIS BOOK AND A NUMBER OF THE
THINGS HE SAID IN THE AFTERMATH
HAVING PROVEN TO BE TRUE.
HE WAS THERE AND HE SAW THIS
ADMINISTRATION WORKED HARD TO
MAKE SURE THE PRESIDENT HAD ALL
THE INFORMATION HE NEEDED TO
MAKE GOOD, SOUND, NATIONAL
SECURITY DECISIONS AND WITH
RESPECT TO THIS ISSUE IN
AFGHANISTAN, I CAN ASSURE
EVERYONE OF YOUR VIEWERS THAT
THIS ADMINISTRATION ACTED IN A
WAY TO PROTECT EVERY AMERICAN
WHO WAS SERVING IN AFGHANISTAN.
WE HAVE FATHER TELL ABOUT HARDER
THAN THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTERS
NEVER DREAMED ABOUT FIGHTING
THEM AND NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
GOING TO PROTECT OUR SOLDIERS BY
WORKING TO GET A PEACE AND
RECONCILIATION DEAL THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO COME HOME.
>> Laura: MR. SECRETARY, YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THESE FORMER BUSH
STAFFERS.
IT’S KIND OF WHAT THEY DID WHEN
TRUMP WAS RUNNING IN 2016.
ALL OF THESE FORMER BUSH
STAFFERS COMING ON SAYING WE ARE
GOING TO SUPPORT JOE BIDEN.
WHAT, WHAT ABOUT THAT?
WHAT DOES THAT REVEAL ABOUT
THEIR ALLIANCES, THE ALLIANCE IS
THAT THEY WILL MAKE IN ORDER TO
DEFEAT DONALD TRUMP?
>> IT’S SAD.
THIS IS AN ADMINISTRATION THAT
HAS EXECUTED ITS NATIONAL
SECURITY FUNCTION IN A WAY THAT
EVERY AMERICAN CAN BE PROUD OF.
BUT IT WAS STRIKING QASSEM
SOLEIMANI OR THE REMARKABLE WORK
WE DID TAKE DOWN THE ENTIRE
CALIPHATE IN SYRIA, TERRORISM.
THE WORK WE’VE DONE TO PUT
PRESSURE ON IRAN.
TO WATCH THESE FORMER OFFICIALS
NOW SUGGEST SOMEHOW FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN IS GOING TO
BE THE RIGHT OUTCOME TO PROTECT
AMERICANS IS JUST SILLY.
>> Laura: WHAT WILL THEIR
CHINA POLICY LOOK LIKE?
FROM WHAT YOU KNOW NOW WITH WHAT
BIDEN BELIEVES IS THE REAL
THREAT TO THE UNITED STATES AND
THE CULTURE WARS, WHAT CAN WE
EXPECT AS AMERICANS AS A POLICY
TOWARD CHINA IF THAT LIKELIHOOD
WOULD COME TO PASS?
>> LAURA, I THINK WE KNOW
BECAUSE WE HAVE EIGHT YEARS OF
HISTORY WITH PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN’S CHINA
POLICY.
THEY DID NOTHING.
WHETHER IT WAS ON THE IMPORTANT
ISSUES WE ARE FACING TODAY ON
HUMAN RIGHTS, WHETHER IT’S IN
TIBET OR HONG KONG OR IN THE
WESTERN PART WHERE UIGHUR
MUSLIMS ARE BEING FORCED TO
CONDUCT ABORTIONS UNFORCED
STERILIZATIONS, THEY DID
NOTHING.
WHETHER IT WAS IN TAIWAN WHERE
THEY REFUSED TO DO THE RIGHT
THING OR PROTECTING AMERICANS
FROM PREDATORY ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY.
COSTING AMERICANS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF JOBS HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE KNOW WHAT THE OBAMA-BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DID WITH RESPECT
TO CHINA.
COWTOWN, PEAS, TURN THE OTHER
CHEEK AND LEFT AMERICA IN A
WEAKER POSITION.
>> Laura: I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
SEEN THIS.
CHINA IS ERADICATING FREEDOM IN
HONG KONG.
HE WARNED ABOUT THIS FOR YEARS
IN "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
REPORTS CHINESE LAW NOW REQUIRES
HONG KONG AUTHORITIES TO
STRENGTHEN REGULATION OF THE
MEDIA AND THE INTERNET AND
EMPOWERS BEIJING TO DEPLOY STATE
SECURITY AGENCIES TO ESTABLISH A
BUREAU OVERSEEING NATIONAL
SECURITY IN HONG KONG.
THEY ARE NOT RULING OUT,
MR. SECRETARY, CHINA IS NOT,
BLOCKING HONG KONG CITIZENS FROM
LEAVING FOR THE U.K.
THE U.K. SAYS YOU WANT TO COME
BACK AND LIVE HERE, COME HERE.
WHAT’S OUR RESPONSE GOING TO BE?
WOULD WE WELCOME THE
HONG KONG-ERS INTO THE
UNITED STATES OF CHINA CONTINUES
ALONG THIS PATH WHICH THEY MOST
CERTAINLY WILL?
>> ALMOST CERTAIN THEY ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE ON THIS PATH.
A FEW WEEKS BACK PRESIDENT TRUMP
MAKE CLEAR THAT HONG KONG WAS NO
LONGER AUTONOMOUS.
I CERTIFY THE SAME, AND WE CAN
SEE THIS IS GOING TO END UP
BEING ANOTHER COMMUNIST RUN
CITY.
IT’S UNFORTUNATE.
HONG KONG WAS SUCH A SPECIAL
PLACE WHERE THERE WERE ALL THE
FREEDOMS THAT THE PEOPLE OF
HONG KONG WERE PROMISED BY THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY AND IT’S
MUCH LIKE THE PROMISE THEY MADE
TO TELL US THE TRUTH BUT WHERE
THE CORONAVIRUS CAME FROM.
WE KNOW IT STARTED IN WUHAN.
WE KNOW IT CAME FROM CHINA YET
THEY COVERED UP FOR AN AWFULLY
LONG TIME.
HAS THE SAME KINDS OF BROKEN
PROMISES THAT WILL LEAD THE
UNITED STATES TAKE THE RIGHT
RESPONSE WITH RESPECT TO
HONG KONG’S NEW NATIONAL
SECURITY LAW.
WE HAVE ALREADY BEGUN THE
PROCESS OF REVOKING VISAS FOR
PEOPLE WHO MADE THESE DECISIONS.
THERE WILL BE A SERIES OF
ACTIONS THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL TAKE.
WE LOVE TO PRESERVE THE FREEDOM
OF HONG KONG BUT IF WE CAN’T, WE
ARE GOING TO HELP CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Laura: FINALLY,
MR. SECRETARY, THE USE CHINESE
APP TICK-TOCK HAS BEEN BANNED BY
INDIA AND AUSTRALIA IS
CONSIDERING THE SAME ACTION
SAYING THAT IT WAS FULL OF MASS
SURVEILLANCE AND PROPAGANDA AND
THAT IT HAD THE ABILITY TO FEED
INFORMATION STRAIGHT TO BEIJING.
KIND OF OBVIOUS QUESTION.
IF IT’S THAT CASE, SHOULDN’T WE
BE CONSIDERING A BAN ON CHINESE
SOCIAL MEDIA APPS, ESPECIALLY
TIKTOK.
>> WE HAVE WORKED ON THESE
ISSUES FOR A LONG TIME.
WE’VE GONE ALL OVER THE WORLD
AND MAKING REAL PROGRESS.
DECLARING THEM A DANGER TO
AMERICAN NATIONAL SECURITY.
WE HAVE DONE THIS.
WITH RESPECT TO CHINESE APPS ON
PEOPLE’S CELL PHONES, WE WILL
GET IT RIGHT.
I DON’T WANT TO GET OUT IN FRONT
OF THE PRESIDENT BUT IT
SOMETHING WE ARE LOOKING AT.
>> Laura: WOULD YOU RECOMMEND
THAT PEOPLE DOWNLOAD THAT APP ON
THEIR PHONES?
>> ONLY IF YOU WANT YOUR PRIVATE
INFORMATION IN THE HANDS OF THE